go kylie go
good job kylie you're doing amazing
sweetie
[Music]
it's the simple things in life that get
chris and kylie jenner excited i'm
having fun typically the mother-daughter
duo lives a pretty lavish lifestyle but
on hulu's the kardashians we see chris
and a pregnant kylie taking it back to
the basics i just think when i'm
pregnant i just want to feel really
normal i have not been to a grocery
store in two years and the new grocery
store forever i want to go to the
grocery stores and pick my own things me
too we need to start getting it's good
for our soul so the duo heads to a
malibu supermarket and that's when the
fun really begins
dreams do come true do you want to push
the basket
kylie
what
oh
nice so great should we buy some support
can't drink it but cute
oh my god there's tater tots that are
sweet potatoes chris admits she stopped
shopping for her own groceries due to
fans in paparazzi swarming which
explains why she's soaking it all up and
freaking out at the checkout line
i just need the experience of checking
out waited for this for years
to be honest do you want to do it no you
do that you guys you do the honors
chippy girl does it have a chance is it
a little chip yep got it thank god
you're here we're approved do y'all want
some help out with this no we want to
push the card ourselves i loved every
minute of it we get to load the car
next up the momager gets a real kick out
of pumping her own guests but it seems
chris and kylie need a bit of a
refresher on how all that works
are you supposed to turn the car oh wait
turn the car off thank you
you had the car on oh
well we didn't blow up that's the good
news it turned off so now what oh
okay
just
like right
rocking
a bike once their tank is full they head
into the drive-through car wash or as
chris likes to call it the happiest
place on earth this says express wash
nine dollars oh that's the one i bought
i'm cheap oh the green light squish
oh
god roll up your window
this is like disneyland
this is fun we have to bring the kids
here oh look it's different colors oh
it's a beautiful rainbow
you know what this is such a tourist
attraction this is the best twelve
dollars we've ever seen
e.t sat down with the kardashian jenner
crew back in april and chris teased
their new show would give a real behind
the scenes look at their daily lives i
love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes and
we think so far they've delivered it's
just so interesting to see it from the
inside out and really get a glimpse of
what happens and how they all balance
what they do
[Music]